you
[Music]
thanks everyone for coming today's
speaker is Huan Yu Jiang
Huan you is a graduate student in
Cornell and this summer he interned in
our group he worked on some cool
projects and differential privacy but
today is going to talk about some of his
other work on privacy-preserving
statistical learning and testing Vanya
okay hello everyone
so thanks Jenna so today I'm vertical I
talking about Hall here and my topic is
on privacy-preserving statistical
learning and high stakes okay so first I
will talk about some introduction the
motivation why we need the statistical
Travis that his role learning and
testing and in the second section and
the third texture is many is Manhattan
apart so the the first problem is on a
differentially provided in he testing
and the second the problem is not
materially private property estimation
and at last I will also measure some
future works okay so let's start with
the introduction and the motivation so
there are some old and the classical
statistical learning and hyeseon
problems the first problem and most of
and maybe most famous ones distribution
learning for example you have some you
have some whole and you also estimate
the pass of a coil okay just a learning
problem and another famous problem is
some hypothesis testing problem problem
for example you have a coil you just
want to theis the wide and all coins are
fair fair or not here Ferguson means it
will show up tail and hide away the same
half probability and the last there are
also some problem name the property
estimation suppose you are given some I
these samples from some unknown
distribution you want to estimate the
property of this distribution for
example you want to estimate the Shannon
entropy of it okay so these are old and
also well started problems but the
problem in us they mainly focus the
previous studies mainly focus on the
small domain setting here the small
domain setting means it has a very small
arthur by size and you have many more
samples compared with a number of the
other by size for example in the example
of alcohol
the ARA Pacis is only true but for now
we want you to look at some other
settings as everyone knows right in the
year of big data so we have the loss or
loss loss of many data and by self data
generally every day and the beauty that
has brought huge success for marshal
oniel statistics but also some new
challenges so what is the new challenges
so now we are not even focusing on the
small domain side here but we want to
focus on some large domains that you
feel are domain setting the reason that
so because we will need you estimate or
test a lot of distributions over large
domains or high dimensions for example
if we want you t always some dream
mutations which is has a really huge
support sighs okay
and also another reason is that we want
you the data is quite expensive
so we want you see use as small number
of data data as possible so today we
will focus more of the focus more on the
final sample setting which means we will
mainly focus on the sample complexity
which is defined as the minimum number
of samples we need to do some tasks okay
and also we also need to consider some
constraint of privacy so and the the
reason it should be obvious because the
samples may contain sensitive
information we just want to do the same
testing or learning problem but we also
want to preserve the privacy for the for
the individuals who contribute data to
us okay and also some more examples on
why we want you on the private data data
may contain some information for example
the medical studies because freedom but
if we want to learn the behavior of
genetic mutations which contains
House reports of disease history or
fitness is why example not data contains
native information and also in some
other application like a lot navigation
because the navigation who suggested
rules based on aggregated positions of
individuals because the position
information can contain a lot of
information and Neha indicates user
residence for example if Google Maps and
me
always either Microsoft maybe he will
find me I'm just actually a staff of
Microsoft right so which means that here
the data is kind of significant
incentive informations okay so what we
want to do it to do some private in
universe okay so what do we want to do
is we won't just want to do the old
problem also always a constraint of the
privacy and the furthermore we want to
explore the privacy sample complexity
trade-off in these problems and neroli
and which will be a fan later so the
sample complexity of these problems can
be divided into two parts the first part
it has a sample complexity of
non-private algorithm and the second
part is just additional cost due to
privacy and then a natural problem an
interesting problem in that is privacy
cause a lot of very small or even free
so why it's important because when the
privacy because it's very small we can
just you incur the constraint of privacy
with very small comments very small cost
okay so now so we first win you some
notation of the privacy here the
notation for privacy we use these a
differential privacy which should be the
most famous one notation for the privacy
and I think I realized should be well
familiar with it but I just want to
briefly go over it the definition is
that will you change one sample in a
data set the output distribution won't
change a lot if we look at the plot the
graph here so you will have two data
sets t 1 and teach you they only differ
at 1 petition for example I'm sorry
so I just change X Y into X 1 Prime so
they only T for either one positions and
I've had it some randomized algorithm
which you need to design by yourself
so the different of privacy just require
not the distribution of the F height on
the condition of the first data set and
the distribution of a I've had any
condition of this set of data cells
should be close here close if some
multiplicity ratio can be bounded by
some Erie's to after and which I found
that will absolutely large you will have
a very weak privacy constraint for
example if you take abs on to be
infinity
you have no constraint of it and even
when you tell us them to be 0 you will
have a very stringent
engines revs the constraint which means
that you need the distribution to be
almost the same
okay so TP is widely used by the
industry for example Microsoft and I
know Google okay so so what was this
random distribution function okay so not
the randomness comes from your algorithm
so now I've had is your algorithm so no
data the data yes
what is the distribution here is it a
fixed rancher or this would be depend on
your data center right well your data
said these are figures that you the
others are either fixed and you you also
have some distributions because our
algorithm is random Oh in that sense
nothing
yeah particularly the inputs can be the
input X or whatever is biggest like you
see anyone just check yes where's Kate
privacy yes and the you can find that
you must use some randomized algorithm
right if you do Salma if you don't use
randomized algorithm you cannot high
above this Karen keep you have the
teacher you can be a bit handle fixed
okay so now okay I just want to talk
about one framework you change
non-private algorithm to private
algorithm okay and we reserve last
mechanism which is the most famous one
so I need you define sensitivity at the
first so the sensitivity of a non-profit
estimator F is defined nice when you
change one dataset when you change one
point in a dataset the possible chin in
the maximum possible change for the
output this is a fully nonprofit
estimator because I'm talking about
changing a non-profit estimator to some
private estimator and you are imagine
that if since it sensitivity is large
which means that free nonprofit active
estimator when you're changing point
either will change a lot in the output
okay so now what is a famous a bloodless
mechanism you can be divided into two
steps the first step is that you design
a nonprofit estimator with low
sensitivity and the second side we just
your proud
this estimator by just adding some blah
blahs noise and you can see here is a
lot less noise with standard deviation
of this an annuity / absol and you can
find that we will Nixon TV is very large
which means that you are non profit
nonprofit estimator is quite bad you
need to add a lot of noise to make it
even really private okay and the epsilon
just the privacy parameter epsilon is
more you have a higher requirement for
the privacy you so you need to add some
more notice of it hmm okay so now we
miss talk with your content follow
jung-hyun works now first work is on P
printer D private high steam and then he
intestine and the colonias testing and
the wit is done by by myself and Chad
which is meadow up with my adviser to
the home with my lab mate and also
another work is done the the visually
private Iestyn made some some property
estimation problem and this is trying to
work with close-up okay so okay so any
problem here now so I just want you to
start at hiding it apart okay so now
first one should be the differential D
private I didn't hear you testing okay
there is a one motivate motivating
example for the for the for the I didn't
he testing so which is a famous and is a
true story is a handle isn't is a Polish
Lottery name the multi logic okay so and
inside not this lottery is fire by
choosing uniformly and random these
thing 20 numbers out of one to 80 okay
so now the problem we concern that in
the lottery fair or not fear fairness
means every number comes out with the
same probability okay so and the answer
for this problem is not there is no so
but also if you draw the histogram of
the 300
yes the three 300 drawings of this
polish multi logic it will find that the
number 50 to 60 is very small so you
will with high probability you can see
that this work should not be a uniform
distribution
right mm-hmm so this is the because the
machine is the best much there is
something wrong with emotions okay so
the more the idea in that we got to want
you see why there is some distribution
is same with our known distribution or
not now we just formalize it by this
problem formulation so this problem is
very famous name dyes I didn't he
testing also cooling ease of feet some
well so namely as one sample test income
so we will see a few sample tends to
test in later so we only have we only
care about the discrete distribution we
see the support size to be k k just 0 1
into K minus -1 and we suppose Q to be
somewhat knowing distribution okay
some known t3 distribution over K now
what is that task that has tree is that
evil acts indifferent you need
independent samples from unknown P x1
into axon we want to answer the
following question whether P hijos cure
or not okay so what is the definition of
our tester our tight search should be
Casa function from the random samples
into 0 & 1 which should studies find the
following things with high probability
our ties the truth output what if P
equals Q okay
you can see the high status kind of a
classifier you just need to justify
wider P and Q are C or they are are far
away in total variation theatres maybe
you will ask me what will happen if if
neither of the Keynesian will satisfy so
the answer is we don't have so you can
let your tester to as true output either
1 or 0 with no guarantee in the problem
clear okay so and we mainly concern
about the sample complexity of this
problem within the smallest and number
of samples we are such a high star uses
and you can find that the sample
complexity should depend on the should
depend on list should on this queue
unknown distribution right suppose you
have some ones for the moon distribution
you can see it should be
independent of the support sighs okay so
here the several capacities defined as a
worst case here the worst case it means
that worst among all than all the cues
although cute here is the some no
distribution on the suppose that's okay
any problem for the problem definition
okay so okay so there is some there are
some previously results so for the
nonprofit problems so the known sample
capacity for this problem is to quite
low K divided by RS square which is
really strong by penske this is tight
okay so we mean you don't need a linear
number of the Union linear number of
samples here linear means the linear
support on the are bite-size you only
need some square root K dependency of it
and I can give you some lower bound
intuition really just a birthday paradox
okay so because we don't have enough
people here so I don't think I can make
a real experiment but the birthday
paradox is that yes suppose you have a
uniform distribution under suppose sighs
okay so I'm you just IIT draw some
samples from this distribution okay so
and only if when you have some square
root K number of samples you can see
some clear the clear means you will see
every you will see I said few samples
which belong to the same seems the same
symbols something like this one and for
this problems we can just show a very
easy argument you prove a square okay
divided by alpha square okay lower bound
for this problem by this birthday
paradox you can just assume you have two
distributions the first distribution is
the uniform on K okay and the second
distribution is you have you have
uniform on hey / - but you don't know
which what is the support of this k / -
okay
so now you just want you these pin which
between these two okay so what you can
do you just randomly draw some samples
and if you
some samples which is less than square
root K McClay mean that four-eyed
furnished few cases you will see the
samples are almost the same because you
can even now see the clear raspy howl
you will see ok every sample appears
with every symbol we only have at most
one sample so from these few cases it
will the samples look is that any the
same so you cannot distinguish between
these two so will gives you a lower
point of square root 8 something okay
so underneath it for the non-private
case and for the absalom different
really private algorithms in the paper
of high and the cost of customs paper so
they show an upper bound of square root
k divided by alpha square plus square
root K log K divided by s MC and you can
stand on this one class is just a cost
of the nonprofit estimator right and
this term it should be the cost because
of the new incurring the constraint of
differential privacy okay so what is the
problem for this estimator because this
this estimate is based on hi squirt
highest which has a very high
selectivity okay so what do we what did
we do we just show that from this
problem we have a height pump of square
located by r square plus the maximum of
these three items and we show is tight
feared hadiza for all the parameter
ranges of K alpha and epsilon okay
good luck oh I see there is this locked
gate down here they're gorgeous and even
if you can run the heater there's still
like where is the exponent solution on
later Bret Hart part of the bottom three
halves but alphasphere dominates no
depends on the value I'm not always we
are concerning the Loctite acres so we
will have a my refuge the IRA buys us a
teddy bear laughs okay yeah so what do
we show in that behind us no more so
when I have so long to be infinite
I am science Kravis the Alpha is some
accurate reliable so our part Arfa is
defined here yeah yeah yeah yeah and
Absalon is yes for the different your
privacy parameter okay so what do we
show you that will have some close to
infinity which means you have no
constraint on the privacy right you will
see these three items will be zero so
you will only have the first item which
we used to wear okay divided by alpha
square which is the cost of for the non
profit estimators okay and also one case
large what we have is a square root K
divided by alpha square a square root
epsilon which is strictly better than
the previous result okay just when
epsilon is privacy saying at some times
P infinity seems a weird statement
proving but I get what you're what you
want to say I just want to say this one
can be happy well once you I mean is
just saying that like if you don't have
a privacy thing straight then why should
I use this algorithm like even the
previous algorithm will also first where
we correct the trivial one yes yeah I
mean it's fine I practically it's fine
but it just seems weird when you say
epsilon you make it infinity
after studying a privacy problem that's
okay
okay so mm what is our contribution so
we have new algorithms for achieving
better ones and we also have new
methodology to prove lower bounds for
this kind of problems I need to point
out the more interesting parts will be
the lower bound to how to prove this is
Ultimo so for all the parameter ranges
and okay so in the first argument I want
to make peace with it I just want to
talk about some reduction from identity
ties into uniform defense team so what
does it mean you just mean that if you
have some okay lets me define uniform in
hesitant first so the island it has been
won't cure is a uniform distribution
over okay so we got the known
distributed as a uniform distribution
over our bioscience okay so my claim is
that if you can solve the uniform it has
two of its null my claim is the previous
works in the non-private case up to
constant factors if you don't care about
constant factors if you can solve the
uniform it has been problem you can also
solve the identity transient problems
you will only without cost of some
constant factors and also we know
uniform it has being should be should
belong to that and it has them right
because uniform distribution just that's
one specialty square distribution on the
support side okay so because we only
care about the worst case guarantee so
we will we can argue that the sample
complexity for this view will be the
same I have two constant factors okay
and what will show you that this one is
all is also true for the private case so
anyone interested in how to do the
reduction okay so suppose now okay what
is the reduction you suppose you have
some uniformly testing algorithm you
want to solve it the salsa I don't hit
hyeseon problem right okay no reduction
is something like you had found out my
pin from from the known distribution to
the uniform distribution and you can
also made the samples in some ways and
even show that if you have Q which is a
known distribution
somewhere far away from here you will
also have some uniform distribution and
somewhat Sikhs are far away from uniform
distribution something like this one yes
enemy dimensional rest
so if you want you had also point out a
special case because if you wanted a
flat has not lot has life distribution
which means that everyone every every
must can be seen eyes so I would like to
see so for year for an eye
she I you know something like something
like a I multiplied she she is um just a
mess so you can see the eyes um so with
mr. ivory forever distribution you can't
be seen as the my integer times the
myself here you guys have something here
so what should be the what should be the
right my team you can just map this one
to be also to be the same on the uniform
distribution this is the two times of it
you just map it by something like you in
the large domain size and this one is to
ryoga's maybe into some three some
things and we need to increase the
balloon size yes yes of course
you can show that so this one yes you
will you will you increase the domain
size from trying to exchange some
constant number of yes but this one is
uh okay so this is only in the special
case of the allotted
lot highest but they also show the the
general my team from so we know the year
like this okay yes
Kassar intuitions of the Alliance okay
so now what I want you to see okay so
now it would be sufficient only to
consider you when you complete I see
right because we show the sample
complexity does say I'm to a constant
number of factors okay so now we just
come to you the algorithms so some we
just see the binary taste first okay now
here a binary case is that is that we
only have our bass aside to beat you
with it as a binary distribution okay so
we just want to distinguish beat you but
only half and the Bernoulli beam and we
just want to tie stop wiser be 0.5 or
alpha away from each other would usually
do for the nonprofit space so you can't
just randomly drawing samples and in let
I'm going to be a number of ones in the
samples and you can imagine that if you
draw just from Bernoulli half the number
and I'm one should be roughly other work
you something that right and we if you
draw something is are far away from 0.5
you will have something like all over Q
plus and plus R for learn something
right so so what should be the red
algorithm for it you can just have some
hard threshold algorithm so for example
and this this is a PDF and this is a
number of ones so if he is a beast
exactly from Bernoulli half you should
be a binomial distribution with the
expectation is actually 1 over 3
multiply something right and if it's not
from the Bernoulli half it should it
should be another binomial distribution
just from 1 over 2 plus alpha multiplied
something right and you had imagine that
were is getting larger and larger
because of the housing tree changing
people of the concentration this one
post needs to you will have a smaller
variance when he's bigger and the
so when the standard deviation is
smaller than a citation cut at the UN
distinguish between these two this is a
rough idea for in on private race
so what should it be you are algorithm
your algorithm should be something like
for here you just output if the number
of one's is smaller than something like
1 over 2 plus alpha over 2 you just
output here is a ok there should be the
probability to output different so I
just want you this is the probability
you are so suppose you have some
randomized algorithm ok so and this
wife's it's just a prop in his output
and they are different ok so what should
be your algorithm you just have 0 here
and and before this threshold you have
zero probability to output they are
different and here you just have a jump
in here you have one and one is larger
than some 1 over 2 plus alpha over 2 you
will just output ok this pew and notice
it this is the case for the this is the
case for the non private case so and
know I know Lisa's is very simple it
just will earn is large enough the
standard deviation will be smaller than
the expectation curve and which will
give you a pound oh well this is a non
private ok so what will happen in the
private so the cost of the ok because of
the different your privacy what does it
mean it means none when you change one
sample you can note that your outputs
probably he'll change you a lot so you
cannot have some some hard search hold
algorithm like this one ok so what
should you do you should just that you
just want to smooth it by some sigmoid
functions
so it just kind of like some idea filter
and some real filters so in a non-profit
case you will have some idea of filters
you just have a huge jump and you'll
lose nothing but you need stiffly
premises because you require you don't
you are not allowed to have a huge jump
in the output of the distribution so
what you do is that it has to use a
sigmoid function to smooth it a new
pressure here
so the algorithm is named some soft
thresholds what you've got something
like okay these the difference between
I'm one man and a difference because I'm
one over two so we just also see
something similar here and so beforehand
we don't have something more the
function we just hide okay if this one
is smaller than zero something we just
output the same I also we all put
different but now we just smooth the
probability by some sigmoid function
okay so right okay
so and this is the analysis of it but
it's not quite important so we need to
prove it by into eyes files the first
aspect is some privacy okay the privacy
guarantee is not hard just by the
property of sigmoid function because we
know that sin and he with he for the I'm
one just of what right so when you
change one sample now I'm one will write
the most exchange Q strange some
concepts okay so so what will what will
happen this one will change I the most Q
so the come up here is something like a
few apps around so you will have here is
to minus epsilon and between you is to
manage eternally used to epsilon we
adjust the requirement for the
differential privacy and also for the
utility and analysis it's also not hard
so you don't need to read this one it's
all kind of messy so the intuition is
that suppose we consider the real
distribution is Bernoulli have okay in
that case I am 1x Almaty the number of
ones in the samples should be roughly
other word to natural suppose a number
suppose number of sample is large enough
so the things in the persons is roughly
miners all miners are fun right so what
do we need is that we need the Absalon
multiplier for to be some concept
because we need to have some huge
concern for the sigmoid function so we
will have some current here like our
four other epsilon to be one so on to be
how about of our overalls are five so
something
and problems you know
so this privacy is insane to one you
know several diversity is our central
model quality
but there are also for the same problem
there are some obvious that the
algorithm without differential privacy
is not already DP yes I think so
why because you can't just so is not a
randomized even though the run not a
randomized algorithm right so in terms
of hand
but hopefully hopefully non-randomized
so suppose you face that it is the
result of the algorithm is fixed right
and we just argue that the non-id
randomized algorithm cannot be
differential Travis
yeah but usually feels like if they are
also doing very collaboratively it
shouldn't change much yes so what do we
yes well what do we do it as a boat your
child what is a low sensitivity non
privatize numerator and we just do this
handles even more the tree but you may
feel friend like okay so I thought what
we are next and see mark just doing
exponential function you don't even do a
lot of last year you don't even do a lot
less noise but he doesn't see the motor
function so it seems a more fancy but
you're not using Oblast now you have
lots of mechanism here and they use that
in verse 8 the other sanity is very
small for the arm works and it doesn't
want okay so now we come to the general
case so the idea is just we just want to
prioritize the statistic used by the
previous papers so like I am at speed
and number of samples so they see the
non-private estimator they use we just
the empirical I all won total we're not
Iowa empirical total total total
distance between the empirical
distribution and under the uniform
distribution so this one has the
following few properties the first one
in the sample Optima in the non private
case and the second property the the
statistic also has a very small Sin City
which so what we do is and and they also
have another some property on the
exploitation crab and the small
sensitivity so they show in their paper
that a citation cut off today's well can
be bounded by the following of three
terms and also unison we also have some
street firms so which match the bungs
Union for our results the three
different items in our
and also it's very easy proof to prove
they had a very small annuity only in
the minimum of 1 + 1 / K we're only the
number of samples and okay there are
biases depending on what is the value of
okay okay so what do we do is you have
this algorithm is very the idea is very
simple so what we do is that we do the
almost the same handoffs trick in the
with the Bernoulli case okay we have
something with just miners - some time
here and we smooth it we are using some
sigmoid function and using usually the
same analysis we can kind of pound
corresponding to does our main theorems
ok so you can see that different you
just need something like this one x
multiplier I'm strong to be smaller than
some concept something like this and you
will kinda pop okay so any problems you
now for the upper bounds I have a
question I don't know problem but so if
this is this actually the right way to
like add noise you guys show that this
is also sort of think of people yeah we
show this much is the lower bounds for
for these problems okay so now comes to
the now comes to a lower bound other
words ok MIT is I think it's more
interesting
so the we have the following lima
suppose there is a coupling between P
and Q over X so anyway I just want to
point out as a no necessarily iid
so such that the Hamming distance
between Alice and one is very small you
can be bounded by T I know we show that
I knew epsilon TP algorithm which can
distinguish between s 2 can be bounded
that I will study if I I was going to be
Omega 1 over T something so what does
the mean is the mass either if you want
to prove some lower bound you need to
find some coupling between P and Q which
has a very small and I use parity
in visas okay so for example if you have
the 90-pound 40 it should be infinity
right so in that case you bill how
absurd is greater you hold and zero it
is nonsense so you just want to find
something some funds find some
distribution which is more happier you
study the Hamming distance as possible
just rough idea okay
so lower bound we have also first we see
a lower bound for the binary case okay
so for any distribution P 1 and P 2 over
X with total variation alpha so if we
draw a lotta samples there must exist
coupling with inside a the Hamming
distance are really the most famous
maximal happening argument right we hold
over a region okay for iid case if you
look at the one sample the total
variation is the probability they need
Nate you are different and now you have
Alan so you will have some mean value
how many turns of an alpha something
like this one right and just by the
unjust by this arguments if we take P to
be an alpha will get n to be greater
than 1 over R 5 so something like this
is the most naive lower bound for this
problem so if we take P 1 to be
Bernoulli 1/2 and P do to be Bernoulli
1/2 plus alpha so we will kinda use that
lower bound for bandages right so and
now the problem is that this point
doesn't have any dependency on K so we
need to find some PI soccer player for
this problem to incur the dependency on
K ok so what is what did we do we just
use some league hands two point method
we construct two hypotheses and not
happening between them with very small
sided Hammond teasers ok so what is the
so what did we do we just design the
following hypothesis - problem the first
hypothesis these charts are these
samples from uniform distribution and
the other one is not only one
distribution is a mixture of a lot of
distributions and you see the
distribution you have seen as a small
perturbation
every position of the uniform
distribution you have some plans to have
some manners something here but you
everyone is are far away from the
uniform distribution and here you can't
use a mixture of it so and we have found
a common distance of uni uniform mixture
to be something like this one so because
of the because of the mist Lima we just
take P to be something by this one we
will get a lower bound of the of our
main theorems and I will skip this okay
and I will also mention another problem
we have a little bit look at in this
paper is a cloning sighting problem also
named that you see what has in the I
think it has been problem we have won
only one distribution known and what
unknown distributor well here what we
have in have we have two unknown
distributions and what what is the
problem setting is that we just draw a
dissembles from here and also from here
so given these two examples we just want
to classify whether P and Q are the same
on they are far away from each other
okay this is a problem of closeness
testing so this is the people in the way
the Allen hit has seen not we don't know
any of the distributors so he has a
strictly harder problem than though and
he testing so in the literature the
pound for the non profit face is Noah is
the analyst height it should be very 2
to 3 over 3 plus 4 okay depending on the
which wise visually is large depending
on the number of the parameter and
depending on the parameter ranges so if
K is quite large the first one will
dominate okay similarly spending process
like problems is there any relation I
don't know I don't know a lot about
those things down
not all of it oh no no but for what do
you think we got found yeah I don't know
this is so decent it's in 24p nice
ladies huh getting the right answer for
it yeah yeah no problem of yours look
there was I think that an original paper
which had like a to the two-thirds from
some time ago this might even be was the
original budget all papers but I think
actually getting this trade-off between
these two terms it's fairly recent yeah
nice the fastest paper for the 1980 as
far as I know we read the paper not this
problem of terms first
yeah but the bond is not short okay so
on the way show we can also prioritize
some now probably estimator to have the
following bonds
we have that you item it should be the
maximum of the following two so and also
okay we skip this one because Jenna
things is very it's very weird so let's
say one case I think yeah that's kidding
so I'm just saying we don't care about
the the prior with privacy with your
hand exactly the same boundaries with a
non private place okay and also it's
supposed to encase large maybe a higher
height bond for this problem when this
is tight because this is just up on the
second her means upon from and eat
healthy right and we know this problem
is strictly harder than the other the
enticing problem so this should also be
a lower bound for this problem so when K
is large labia or guys are tied a lower
bound one for this problem okay so
conclusion for this first work so what
do we do is that we establish a general
happy matter to prove lower bounds we
also have the optimal sample complexity
we also give some some capacity of
closes testing okay I will go over the
second work quickly
okay so in this work we also consider
the differential privacy setting but we
consider another problem is between the
property estimation fear the property is
some property of some distribution
suppose we have some P on which reason
only square distribution so and we want
us
I'm here which is some property of these
tributaries ample entropy you should be
the property of the distribution itself
okay an RV is a multi reliable
now you input is some iodine poles
rolling from P and the one we want to do
is that we want to output some estimator
I've had such that with the high
probability
now sorry yeah the isolator should be
closed with the real value with the
accuracy level are always high
probability something like so and we
also want to know the sample home
velocity for this problem which is the
least number of samples to estimate a
speed I mean the problem clear so and
transferring is your high probability
question you know it will you video
tricks but it's not clear in the
predator ah even then it's not clear but
anyway yes I think since we are running
late I just want to just go back once by
any standard so in our FB is just sound
property of this okay okay so now what
we okay we also consider the people
ready private property I see major
problem so we require our estimator to
satisfy the first is accuracy the same
accuracy as the previous slide and the
second as user privacy we also in our
estimator must study if i I've sound
definitely privacy it's also global
differential privacy mode okay so we
consider the following three properties
the first one in the shadow entropy the
second one is a support coverage which
is the healthy number of these things
symbols if we draw am sample from P okay
so what I want to explain more about it
suppose we have some unknown
distribution and we draw am samples of
it okay and the you will see and uh okay
let asked to be the random variable
which indicates the number of the
different symbols which will appear
among the samples you should be a random
variable right but here we consider it's
healthy number of it so we should be a
fixed value I will explain more for this
ones and I'm
nice wise I run your example last which
means our support size which is a number
of symbols with nonzero probability
which is easier to understand okay this
is a I example the underlying assumption
I don't mention that we assume everyone
has probability 1 over K so yes yes oh
because if you have something which
appears very small probability you need
to say that with a very large size of
samples right yeah it really is
impossible if you don't have anything in
number of samples ok I don't have time
for this
motivating examples so yes ok so it's
just a second electrons what you're
saying is just like generalization of
coupon collector kind of problem oh yes
yes so when you draw some III mean
coupon collector is kind of like the
opposite direction how many times until
you definitely see it everything and
that takes sort of like a log cake right
so me I am then how many will see okay
yeah and there's the other way in the
sense that you'll be able to save a log
k but maybe a boiling question what
Signum of is a simple application of
inequality sorry there might be so his
initiative that means the sharing of
power argument that because s is
Lipschitz right I guess the real bonus
so what what you want to say follows
directly from I think Mac the are
miracles because this is a vicious
function on a what am i up yet
okay so if you have a subset of M
examples and you change one of them they
stop so define the function there
example M examples and I look at the
trend listing writings right so this is
my function this relationship
okay but the problem this one only works
when you have okay it only works with M
is very small so okay so okay let me put
it in this way suppose you have some
suppose has okay these were only words
when you have a lot of samples larger
than say but if you have only required
somewhere is small sample compared with
them this one does yeah well but this is
true when you have us it meant much more
samples
Helen your comments I guess like what
you're saying is exactly correct if you
had more than app draws from P it group
it up into the sets of size M into C
with the value that this will
concentrate but the surprising thing
that he'll show it you can do this with
far fewer than AB draws from P right oh
yes okay slice example
so our main results are the host of
privacy in probably the property
estimation is also negligible okay so
now same for all these three problems I
will only talk about the supposed hard
problems this is our upper bound so in
this upper bound you can see the first
one is tight for the nonprofit case it's
optimal and the second one is upon for
the for the cost of privacy and we can
show that the privacy is free analyzed I
have said on to be very very very small
so because what suppose I've come to be
something like 1 over something like for
some constant you will see this will
have almost no cost of your privacy any
problem and we all right maybe I need to
stress this bound only works when the
I'm is very large I am is greater than 1
over R 5 or something so maybe you're
curious why this to one is why it's
strictly larger than this one is because
we have some assumption that we are in
the M is very large size
okay so yes so we just shown that the
privacy house it's very small here's
what all what we do each other a lot
less the mechanism which are our already
hard work so I found one the bottom
without your own privacy is likely beer
so you're saying that we estimate the
expected number of like the support
coverage you may actually need mor log M
Sam yes you don't need more than samples
because you are only interested in an
open this was hired for any parameter so
doughnut you still use IBM samples right
you help me you that is they I'm samples
or comes in number of is okay so what do
we do is just a Laplace the mechanism we
follow the following nonprofit estimator
from honestly so where some lost
Nativity so what do we do is that we
found those Nativity of this one and we
can i some loveless noise and we show
the bounds in the onion our main
theorems and also we use happening lima
so we could be already used in that
hyeseon problem so two to three lower
bound for this problem the kid on this
one is really harder than that
above this heightened problem right if
you want to use for example if you have
the UN is uniform over this one and
YouTube is distributed over n plus one
so we will have one huge mass of about
alpha divided by 1 plus alpha and I
remind the same win this one
so you and when I showed that the
support heritability for by alpha AB and
if you guys remain this one either Italy
you can also distinguish between its two
okay
I say so with so we got to use a poem
from the habit of testing and show a
lower bond knock people over half absol
mm-hm and we also do some experiments so
we just show the real prodigy meters and
the number of estimators doesn't differ
a lot on the agility okay so also are
some real data sites so conclusions or
upon show that
some privacy is also negligible and with
you have some lower bound for these
problems and also we show it that you
felt hearing is of it you buy some
synthetic on the real do that samples
okay I think this is for for today so
yes I don't have an tongue power it any
problems with my your questions so I
have one good so like here this one
sample seems like I'm more interested in
seeing that since the privacy almost
comes for free right
like how many samples I need to change
before I actually like have any
background or switch problem and he has
to any of these settings like so in your
now the or applying strict differential
privacy definition where you change only
one sample but suppose I allowed the
epsilon fraction of the samples do you
think many of these things will like
when will they break recommend what is
the sensitivity goes out so like because
oftentimes people already have this like
there are because this one sample it
seems to Strix
like oftentimes there is a good fraction
of the samples coming from this name
user and this may be the set of problems
were actually I mean differential
privacy once you quantify this right
like you know if you do like changing
two things you have a two epsilon
guarantee yeah but that's what I'm
saying right yeah but here when really
break ripening like but I also like here
could be able to show some amplification
kind of thing so it's not like I think
you can get better is that yes I don't
think my competition is the right answer
for this yes so I'm thinking so for
example if we only look at the example
of the Bernoulli the polluter Bernoulli
case we have some whole line of this
water right so when you so will you
change suppose n is very large all your
chains up comes a fraction already the
will not create the apartment exactly
actually see like whether you can show
bonds which are like which we can buy Co
bypass one strong opposition
I said yeah I mean yeah the crew but my
statistics it should be pretty easy to
analyze because often the privacy it
just done by sort of a gap into not only
not very sure dollar they do for
citizens yes your house yeah ghosts of
all you are here what actually need to
change a lot of almost around Omaha half
of it yeah that's what make it a
breakdown but on the other hand if I
simply walk strong competition then if
we're going to give you this strong
character
sure I think there is some work but I'm
not quite familiar great but oh you're
saying there is some works my visor
Kostas desk life work some on this and
other other people at but like I can
link you to some a furious understudying
differential photos yeah yeah I do
differential privacy
cool Oh give no questions